all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag anybody can be on the mailbag
you simply have to write into info
davidpackman.com we have a whole bunch
of different types of emails that we get
we get policy uh uh deep policy wonk
type emails we get superficial
criticisms we get praise and we also get
trolling and today we're going to start
with just a little bit of trolling it's
always good just to get a sense of the
types of things I get Peter wrote in and
Peter says you're a political hack empty
vessel are you ever going to take that
war criminals phallus out of your mouth
and you're as y o u apostrophe re
out of you are mouth you pro-imperialist
Progressive boot licking peasant brain
loser no wonder you have a for-profit
opinion show not a new non-for-profit
newscast you don't do news You Preach
one-sided BS what's very interesting is
this is from a left Winger
this is left-wing hate mail they believe
I am an imperialist and not really a
progressive and that I just love Joe
Biden the supposed uh uh Imperial
imperialist war criminal and that the
fact that this is not a non-profit show
is part of the problem now what's funny
is he kind of agrees with Alex Jones in
a sense oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad yeah so
yes my show like basically every other
YouTube podcast show uh is not a
non-profit a lot of people might not
even realize to have a non-profit you
need a board you need I mean it's it's
actually quite complicated to be a
non-profit and it doesn't really make
sense for a whole bunch of different
reasons we considered it at one point
um these are folks who are in the you
can never be Progressive enough category
and that's why I flagged this one we get
a lot of right-wing hate mail but the
left-wing hate mail is also interesting
because in theory Peter is someone with
whom I probably agree 95 of the time
maybe even 98 of the time but this is
exactly the type of stuff that hurts the
left and you really hate to see it
but I can't control it it is what it is
Vincent wrote in Vincent now this is
right wing hate Vincent is a very
anti-semitic Vincent says Pac-Man why is
the left woke crowd so dominated by Jews
without Jew support the left would die
on the vine same is true for wokism only
the financial and intellectual support
from Jews allows wokism and leftism to
continue their evil existence why do
most Jews support such evil
yikes so remember you know a bunch of
different things
um Jewish Americans much like black
Americans are a very left-wing voting
block one of the most left-wing voting
blocs in the country
um when it comes to wokism as defined I
guess by Vincent
it's a relatively small part of what
there is on the left I think it's
extremely over represented in social
media and extremely overrepresented by
right-wing media but sometimes when they
say wokeism you know I've talked about
where there can be excesses sometimes on
the left and I say sure I can talk about
this but these aren't like huge deals on
the left
sometimes what the right means by
wokeism is we're against treating people
terribly because of their identity
that's considered wokeism earlier in the
week we had this clip of this Republican
Mom saying I don't like all this Marxist
stuff like anti-bullying
sometimes that's what they mean they're
just really angry that it's not okay to
criticize people who don't look or sound
like you anymore so anyway uh pathetic
stuff anti-semitic stuff for sure but
very very common out there
um oh here's a nice uh nice voicemail
about my recent interview with Adam
Steen
my compliments I was quite impressed
with your interview of Adam Steen of
Wisconsin I really don't know how many
interviewers could keep such an even
Keel when faced with some of the
responses Adam had my compliments to you
sir yeah I get this question a lot like
in my personal life as well how do you
remain so cool with these people there's
two parts of it one is just the
experience of doing it
the second part sadly is a little bit of
desensitization when you've heard this
crazy stuff for a decade and a half
you do become somewhat desensitized to
the level of depravity
that is exhibited by many of these folks
and I don't know that that's a
particularly good thing because I'm sort
of suffering from a normalization in a
sense I'm still against the things they
say
but I'm used to hearing them when they
are very much not normal so something to
think about Ryan wrote in about
preventing life also the notion from the
Adam Steen interview
and Ryan says hey David the notion of
preventing life is completely absurd
you're possibly preventing life with
nearly every action you take for example
I didn't get my morning coffee today
because I was running late therefore I
didn't happen to run into my future wife
therefore we didn't go on to have
children thereby preventing a life any
action can be seen as preventing a life
thanks David Ryan from Milwaukee yeah
it's sort of like a um
it's like a chaos theory on right-wing
brain worms Adam Steen was saying not
only is he against
uh birth control I'm sorry not only is
he against abortion he's against birth
control as well because you're
preventing life
very very weird argument and it didn't
make it it seemed he even seemed
confused by it quite frankly Carl wrote
in Carl says are you streaming any
debates I'm in Pittsburgh and would love
to see you do a stream of fetterman
versus Oz or Shapiro versus mastriano oh
and a silly name suggestion for the
financial show Pac-man the financial
fact men okay yeah so I have a whole
bunch of different streams that are
scheduled when it comes to debates
um tonight we've got Abbott versus Beto
next week we have JD Vance versus uh Tim
Ryan and then we have uh Mark Kelly
versus Blake Masters the week after that
we've got DeSantis versus Chris Whitmer
versus Tudor Dixon and if it happens the
Raphael Warnock vs Herschel Walker
debate although who the hell knows
whether any of those debates are going
to happen week after that we've got
Rubio versus Val demings if it gets
confirmed Oz versus fetterman and then
the week after that uh nothing scheduled
yet so there's there's actually close to
like a dozen different debates that I
plan on covering and I hope you'll join
me for those Dan wrote in David sir why
doesn't fetterman just take the Montreal
cognitive assessment exam I would love
to see Republicans make light of the
very exam Trump has been bragging about
for years yeah we had a voicemail caller
last week with a similar idea which was
basically Trump took a dementia stroke
brain injury test and brags about it
like it gets him into Mensa
if fetterman took it who fetterman had a
stroke and now there's people saying oh
he can't think whatever
um if fetterman took it and passed it
would Republicans then be satisfied and
the answer is of course not they would
all of a sudden say it's not sufficient
we it's
I I know that Hannity and Trump and
everybody brags about this test like
it's the be-all end-all of intelligence
and cognition but if it was what
fetterman said and by the way I got an
email from a neurologist in our audience
who said you know David it's not a what
if
almost certainly fetterman was given
that test that assessment because he had
a stroke and it's typical that that's
what you do it's not used for what Trump
used it for it's stunning stunning stuff
uh then a different Dan wrote in about
our YouTube thumbnails now this I want
to address in some serious some depth
Dan says those YouTube thumbnails that
involve a ridiculous facial expression
dude please don't do that anymore your
content is remarkable and consistent and
on point you don't need that cringy kind
of gimmickry much love Dan listen guys
they're just YouTube thumbnails okay I
get it there's things that there are
Trends on YouTube and other platforms
that are kind of gimmicky okay sometimes
they're even a little cringy but one of
the things we do is we adapt
if we did our titles today are
dramatically different than what they
were a decade ago okay the conventions
and what does well on our different
platforms change over time
titles have changed our set has changed
the audio equipment has changed how the
show is produced has changed and yes
thumbnails change and sometimes we test
thumbnails where I have a goofy look on
my face okay
if that alone
makes you not want to watch or listen to
the show anymore
then I'm sorry because really the
content is what what I would hope would
be most important but we're rolling with
the changes if you don't adapt you die
in our space so listen if those funny
faces don't do well we'll stop using
them if they go out of style we'll stop
using them if they hurt us we'll stop
using them but we're just testing
different things that's all all right
please folks with peace and love Barney
wrote in about something that is really
really important
Barney wrote to me and said America is a
food desert
David Englishman traveling through the
USA here currently in Chicago
I speak to a lot of Europeans on my
travels and we are shocked that much of
the U.S is a food desert and that we are
all completely undernourished and cannot
follow a typically healthy diet we might
adhere to in Europe it's impossible to
find cheap healthy food literally
anywhere writes Barney
it costs seven dollars for a salad
thirteen dollars for a foot long Subway
for example I even found it's more
expensive to buy Florida oranges in
Florida than it is for me to get Spanish
oranges in England yes I understand
inflation is a factor but this is
happening everywhere and despite this
growth reason groceries and healthy
foods in particular are obscenely
expensive
I think the reason
is you have one National Supermarket so
there's no competition and there are a
general lack of supermarkets compared to
the UK so this part I don't know I we
have more than don't we have I mean
there's Trader Joe's there's Whole Foods
um
there's
well that's actually interesting is is
Wegmans National I'm not even sure maybe
Barney's on to something maybe we only
have like two national Supermarket
chains like I know Stop and Shop is just
a Northeast thing I believe
uh yeah that that may be a problem
listen Barney is completely correct and
a lot of people you know when I've
traveled through
the Midwest small towns in the Northeast
typically have great food and plenty of
supermarkets you know uh Upstate New
York and Vermont and you know Maine
these play there's typically no issue
but when I've been in like Wisconsin
when I've been in Northern Indiana when
I've been in um even Kansas City
Missouri it's like okay right in the
city but then it gets a little bit rough
it is a major problem and there's
multiple problems there's the the
pricing issue of course
the food desert issue where there are I
mean even even in New York and Boston
there are poorer neighborhoods with a
dearth of options other than chain
restaurants and there's also a lack of
Education sadly as to what constitutes a
healthy diet what does it mean to eat a
healthy diet well I don't know I eat I
eat chicken and vegetables but what do
you mean well yeah I mean it's wings
that I fried as well as you know mashed
potatoes exclusively right they're fries
whatever
there are definitely misunderstandings
about how a diet should be established
and honestly part of the problem is that
that old school food pyramid also was
somewhat inaccurate and confusing so
Barney you have correctly pointed out
that uh there's a lot of problems with
food here in the United States and it's
really like trying to you're kind of
like trying to dig yourself out
but as you do it you're digging another
hole
I don't know if it's the right metaphor
get your emails into me info
davidpackman.com tell me your stories of
food deserts probably worthy of a clip
coming up soon and we will see everybody
on today's bonus show which you can sign
up for at
joinpakman.com coupon code indict that's
the coupon code everybody knows why the
coupon code is currently in diet
we need some indictments the evidence is
there it's time see you on the bonus
show or otherwise back here on Monday